chairman of the district council
come on please be seated
great
good evening members and officers of
council and members of the present
public i welcome you to this meeting of
the council
now if the firearm is activated please
vacate the building via the emergency
exits
with respect to filming of the meeting i
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured i urge
anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly and if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film a meeting
this evening
and i don't see anyone
any filmmaker recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
there's a restriction on the use of
mobile phones as well would everyone
present please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent and they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
whilst the meeting is progress in
progress
now with respect to the use of
microphones in order to be heard clearly
at this meeting please can members stand
up remove your mask and wait for the
microphone to be
brought to you
when the microphone is presented please
speak directly into it
i
go through these every council meeting
and
they are important so it's as well that
they're said so moving straight to
agenda item one apologies for absent now
i have apologies received from
councillors bambridge dennis hart moore
and towning do i have any other
apologies this evening
um apologies from uh councillor green
chair
councillor
green councillor green do i have any
other apologies
i don't see any
thank you very much
generation two minutes of the previous
meetings agenda item 2a the meeting held
on the 15th of july 2021
i knew that the minutes of the council
meeting held on the 15th of july 2021 be
approved and signed as a correct record
please go have a seconder
thank you
agenda item 2b the minutes of the
extraordinary melting held on the 23rd
of september 2021
i move that the minutes of the
extraordinary council meeting held on
the 23rd of september 2021 be approved
and signed as a correct record please
can have a seconder
count for scoby this time
second time lucky
demos agree
thank you
now moving on to agenda item three
announcements i do have an announcement
the external auditor's recommendations
would members please note that in
response to the recently received
auditor's recommendations
an extraordinary council meeting will be
held within a month to consider the
auditor's recommendations
the item is not on the agenda for this
evening's meeting
we are expecting in fact i believe is
the case um democratic services that the
meeting will be the second of november
tuesday the 2nd of november
and both adjudicators will be coming
so moving on to agenda item 4
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
and in connection with this perhaps
members should declare any interest in
conjunction with agenda item eight
uh
motions we have a motion on airbnbs if
there is any counsellor who feels the
need to make
any declaration for interest i don't see
any any other declarations of interest
no
agenda item 5 petitions now no petitions
have been received in accordance with
council procedure rule 12.
so moving straight on therefore to
agenda item six questions from the press
and public
now this evening four questions have
been received from members of the public
in accordance with council procedure
rule number 13
please note that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question
could the questioner please only state
the name of the cabinet member to whom
their question is to be put and read out
the exact wording of the question that
they're submitting to this council
so therefore within the general item 66a
question numb a one from a member of the
public regarding clinical waste
collection
and please welcome mr thompson to the
meeting mr thompson could you please
make your way to the front table
are you with us mr thompson
we don't see mr thompson we don't you're
not giving permission
we will uh therefore provide mr thompson
with an answer to his question in
writing
yeah i'm afraid so councillor bayford
it does happen
you're looking forward to this weren't
you
members he was going to answer this one
you see
agenda item 6b question number two from
a member of the public regarding
swimming at your leisure facilities and
please welcome hopefully this time miss
kimber to the meeting miss kimber could
you please make your way to the front
table
[Music]
god
this is addressed to council thank you
councillor george cupp
swimming is important to young children
for exercise and we've found its
extensive coastline for their safety all
baby and preschool swimming lessons at
the pools managed by your leisure are
now exclusively provided by a private
organization
paddle ducks these can be much more
expensive than those offered directly by
your leisure for older children at
fifteen pound per lesson for polar ducks
could the council explain why such an
exclusive agreement was made and how it
is in the best interest of than its
children
well thank you for that miss kimber i
call upon councillor cop to respond
you chair and thank you mr kendra for
coming in for your question today um we
agree that swimming is an important
exercise for all age groups however we
are as a council unable to comment on on
the substance of your question as your
leisure is an independent organization
um and set their prices independently
from the council but what i would say is
that outside of this meeting if you
would like to email me i'm very happy to
have further conversations with you to
see what possibly we can do whether it's
in meetings or situations like that and
see where we if we can get to some kind
of agreement with uh your leisure all
right
thank you councillor cup and that seems
to have been well received agenda item
6c question number 3 from a member of
the public regarding the protection of
venues from complaints
i'm pleased to welcome mr randall to the
meeting mr randall could you make your
way to the front table please
thanks
join the clarification to the question
as well or just the main question
the initial
so the question was originally directed
to
reece pew
um
what is stanic doing to value and
protect new and existing hospitality and
music venues from complaints the likes
of which see such establishments shut
down in order to appease a minority of
residents who choose to live next to or
within
buildings and areas of higher historic
and cultural
artistic and economic importance
further has sanic considered following
the city of liverpool and others in
adopting the agent of change
or seeking to apply data easement
to venues that would warrant it
thank you mr randalls i called upon
councillor davis to respond
[Applause]
i'm sorry you've got the uh
substitute uh
the question was uh directed to
councillor pew but um
uh can i just thank you mr randall uh
for the question and also for you
mentioned the additional clarification
which was received thank you very much
in our response i would confirm that a
deed of easement is a right exercised
over a piece of land or property for the
benefit of another and is a private
action taken by individual landowners
not the local authority
paragraph wally 7 of the national
planning policy framework outlines that
planning policies and decisions should
ensure that all new developments can be
integrated effectively with existing
businesses and community facilities
whilst not explicitly cited in the 2020
local plan the council considers the
need for applicants to provide suitable
mitigation
in new housing proposals if the new
development would result in unreasonable
restrictions
on existing facilities including music
venues
this includes requiring acoustic surveys
and ceiling insulation to mitigate the
transmission of noise
we also notify all neighbouring
properties adjacent to sites and
proposals to ensure that we are seeking
the comments of residents and businesses
about planning applications
thank you
thank you very much council saunders
thank you mr randalls
agenda item 6d i have question number
four from a member of the public
regarding travellers community at
ramsgate port
and please welcome miss shotton to the
meeting miss shotgun could you please
make your way to the front table
good evening everyone sir
it is increasingly apparent that we are
heading for a humanitarian disaster this
winter for our vulnerable travellers
community currently housed at ramsgate
court unless a permanent safe suitable
site
is identified for them by tdc as
required under the housing act 2004 and
its attendant regulations
under human rights legislation access to
regular healthcare and settled schooling
are among the primary entitlements of
these families
at present lacking the most basic
requirements such as access to toileting
facilities
their situation is one of which we
should all feel ashamed
can you report what urgent action is
being taken by officers to identify
sites
and move this most important project
forward so that these families among the
most disadvantaged of our fanatic
community can access the healthcare
mental health support and education they
so desperately need
thank you very much miss shotton i call
upon cancer cop to respond
thank you chen and thank you mr sharpton
um the council commissioned a study for
the local plan examination which
identified a cultural need for seven
permanent pitches and five transit
pitches one of the key aspects of the
local pan update is to allocate suitable
sites to meet the identified need
separately a site search was undertaken
by the council to identify possible
emergency stopping sites for gypsies and
travelers this is now included in the
local plan work a call for sites was
undertaken in early 2021
the submissions will be assessed through
the local plan processes
council offices
officers are also looking for for other
potential sites including those in
public ownership to meet the identified
needs but also what i would like to add
to that is that um finding a long-term
solution is this cabinet's priority as
well thank you
thank you very much indeed counselor cup
anti-miss schotten
that concludes questions from members of
the public this evening so moving on to
agenda item seven questions from members
of this council
agenda item 7a question number one from
a member regarding southern water and
discharges into the sea and i have this
from councillor yates council yates
thank you chair um this question for
councillor pugh
um does councillor pugh agree with me
that
following raw sewage being dumped along
planet's coastline that is worrying that
southern water being unable to confirm
in writing that the permitted pumping
speeds required a market pumping station
of 809 liters per second have been met
over the past couple of years thank
you
thank you councillor yates councillor
pugh
thank you councillor yates uh for your
question
uh the regulator body regulator body for
the authorization of discharges from the
pumping station is the environment
agency
and as part of the authorization and
as part of the authorization there will
be conditions to control discharge while
these issues have been raised for the
environment agency any such breaches
would be enforced by them and i'm sure
councillor yates is aware that we
continue to liaise with southern water
and the environment agency on the
instances that happen along our shore
thank you
thank you councillor pugh councillor yes
do you have a supplementary um i do as
you might expect um yeah thank you very
much for that answer um i have actually
had it confirmed by the environment
agency this week
um that they have opened a criminal
investigation
uh based on the sewage incident on the
16th of june 2021 at margate pumping
station
um
can council pugh confirm if he is aware
that if the broad stairs incident is
also under a criminal investigation by
the environment age
by the environment agency have they
opened up a criminal investigation thank
you
thank you councillor yes council pew are
you able to answer that
thank you council yates in response to
your question uh they haven't yet uh but
for any investigation needs to take
place
before they do and but of course once we
know any information i'll be more than
happy to share that with you and all
members of the council thank you
thank you very much councillor pugh
moving on to agenda item 7d question
number two from a member regarding
safety boys
uh
i pour upon counselor alvin
yeah thank you chair
this is for
councillor pugh
uh can you please tell me why no safety
boys were located off and along the main
beaches
to protect swimmers and beach users from
jet skis etc in accordance with the
council's approved beach action plan
thank you
thank you councillor uh alban of course
this is boys built with a b-u-o-y-s
so the floating variety
councilor
puke thank you chair and i can confirm
there's definitely not our young
children tied to anchors located off our
coast not by the council
um or not because of us by any stretch
of imagination uh thank you councillor
auburn for your question um i've been
reliably informed by officers that the
boys have been put out on the agreed
locations at the start of the summer
season at the following beaches we've
got minis bay west space mildred's bay
westbrook bay margate and rams game
thank you
thank you council puke because album do
you have a supplementary i do chair um
just hearing the answer to that
question
um as around to get east cliff landscape
council i can confirm that no boys were
placed outside or along
ramsgate beach
um
because of that i believe that that our
visitors and residents
will put at risk
and i would ask how to put whether he
thinks uh our residents have been put at
risk
thank you
thank you councillor album councillor
pugh
thank you chair and thank you council
alvin for your supplement question um i
think it goes about saying that the
council's number one priority is the
safety of all of our residents and
visitors particularly along our
coastline and all water users should be
able to enjoy the coastline as safely as
possible and we'll certainly look into
that if that's not the case and it'll be
remedied but you know i'm well aware
that usa award members have received
emails from residents
and will continue to look into it and
let's hope that we can try and find a
medium that everyone's happy with thank
you
thank you very
much pugh
agenda item 7c question number three
from a member regarding airbnbs
i call upon councillor bailey
councillor bailey
thank you chair
uh my question concerns the shortage of
rental properties and the associated
proliferation of airbnbs
um i have been increasingly aware of the
plight of local residents desperate to
find places to rent in thanet i even
know of a lady in her 80s who was issued
a section 21 notice but still not been
able to find anywhere else to rent in
thanos and she's
she's temporarily living with her
brother
the current lack of availability of
rental property seems to be exacerbated
at least in part by the increasing
proliferation of airbnbs
a shortage of rental properties will
eventually put more pressure on the
authority in terms of having to find
additional temporary accommodation to
house people so this is a serious
problem which could have ramifications
for the council
i would like to ask what is the council
doing or indeed what power does it have
perhaps through the review of the local
plan to address this issue do we know
actually how many airbnbs there are in
the district and is there a local
requirement to register airbnbs with the
authority and if not do you think there
should be thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much i call upon
councillor jill bayford to respond who i
presume has also spent a week preparing
like a husband
thank you chair and thank you councilman
for the question
the council's adopted local plan
includes an assumption that six point
three percent of the local housing stock
is second homes which potential
potentially includes holiday lets and
the housing requirements set out in the
plan take this into account
this equates to around four thousand
dwellings
the local plan also has policies that
both support the retention of
residential dwellings policy ho22 and
support the provision of self-catering
accommodations as part of the local
touring tourism
industry sorry policy e08
the intention of policy ho22
was to protect existing housing supply
there are some caveats of which one is
tourism use but only where it meets the
policy criteria
poor location unsuitability for
residential use or heritage impacts
in the event that planning positions
required for a holiday let of this kind
the policies in the adopted plan are
probably sufficient
however the policy ho22 can only be
applied when there is a material change
of use of a dwelling
in a signal in a significant number of
cases it is unlikely that there will be
a material change of use
from a residential dwelling to a holiday
let
for example where a whole dwelling is
left to a single family for their
holiday
however the council considers all
planning enforcement complaints in
relation to short-term accommodation to
assess whether a change of use has
occurred
looking at the specific factors in each
case
any new local planning policy
specifically in relation to holiday
letting would need to be based upon
robust evidence about how this impacted
on the supply and affordability of local
homes to meet locally identified needs
there is no current requirement to
register an airbnb or any other form of
holiday let not included hotels and hmos
that are covered by different
legislation
with the local council
as a result we do not currently hold
definitive figures
however airbnb have indicated that their
platform has up to
1316 listed properties
it is not clear whether these are whole
dwellings or parts of dwayne
a 2019 survey completed by visit kent
identified
1089 active airbnb rentals in planet
which does suggest that the recent trend
in people holiday in the uk following
the kobig 19 pandemic has fueled a rise
in the number of airbnbs
the mandatory registration or the
effective planning control of holiday
lets would require new national
legislation or regulation
a number of national organizations
that's the b association tourism
alliance etc have been lobbying for
change and asking for a registration
scheme to be introduced
as part of the government's tourism
recovery plan published in june one of
the key initiatives was to launch a
consultation on the introduction of a
tourism accommodation regeneration
scheme
the conservative
administration is committed to
determining the impact of airbnbs on the
rental market in planet but this must be
weighed against value to our visit your
economy which supports local employment
thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
bayford
it's uh it's an emotive issue but quite
clearly very complicated do you have a
supplementary counselor bailey
uh yes could i come back thank you
councillor aphid um of course there's no
doubt in the economic benefits that
short term let's bring to the district
but there does need to be a balance
between the availability of rental
accommodation for local residents and
provision of short-term laps airbnb has
actually started offers you know renting
rooms in houses but now
they're but they're buying up housing
stock valuable housing stock for our you
know from our residents
the email we received from professor uh
professor marina novelli today regarding
the proposed white paper was very
interesting and gave some hope and some
direction towards future regulations of
airbnbs i just wondered what castle
bailey
just wondered what tdc's response is to
the white paper thank you
thank you uh back to you councillor
bayford
thank you council bailey uh yes we will
receive the email that you refer to and
as you can see they're looking for
national
regulation which this this
administration certainly supports thank
you
thank you very much indeed councillor
bayford
agenda item 7d question number four from
a member regarding the availability of
affordable housing i call upon
councillor austin
thank you chair
um another one for councillor joel
bayford um and again
on a similar topic at a recent drop-in
session the director of housing and
planning highlighted current pressures
on affordable housing in sanet
occasioned by rapidly rising private
center sector rents the reduced number
of properties available for rent and the
various modest number of new properties
we as a council have been building each
year what strategies is cabinet adopting
to address these issues and in
particular to increase the number of
council-owned properties available for
rent thank you
thank you councillor austin councillor
before during the wars this evening two
in a row
thank you chair and thank you councillor
austin for the question
the council has adopted a detailed
housing homelessness and rust sleeper
strategy which sets out the council's
proposals providing affordable homes
the strategy is available on the
council's website
the strategy includes a strategic
objective to improve access to and
supply of housing including affordable
homes it set out a detailed action plan
and progress is reviewed by the housing
cabinet advisory group
in particular the strategy sets out how
the council and its housing association
partners are working together to
increase the supply of affordable homes
and the action that the council is
taking to bring empty homes back into
use
over the past nine years the council has
constructed or acquired 162 new homes
for affordable rent and has proved
funding in place for a further 28 new
homes
these programs have been supported with
a total investment of 40 sorry 4.3
million pounds
primarily from capital funding from the
council's housing revenue account
with additional support including the
right to buy receipts and homes england
grant
the total funding available for
investment in sway is limited by the
capacity of the council's hra
to release capital funding or support
borrowing
the current business plan projections
include provision for further investment
of around 8.1 million pounds annually
from 2024
which will prudently provide at least 30
new homes each year year
the housing cabinet advisory group are
due to consider the latest business plan
projections at its next meeting and
these will be represented cabinet and
council as part of the budget setting
process 2022-23
in addition to the council's
activities new affordable homes for rent
are provided by our housing association
partners
these homes are either provided in
partnership with private sector house
private sector house builders through
section 106 agreements or supported by
grants from homeless homes england with
a bulk of funding coming from housing
association's own business plans
the pace of delivery is strongly linked
to the pace of private sector house
building and the council works closely
with the private sector house builders
to facilitate the delivery of approved
homes
this year we'll see 66 housing
association homes completed in the in
the district and with a number of
strategic sites coming forward this is
set to increase in 2022 23 to around 350
homes
although these programs demonstrate the
commitment that the council deliver more
affordable homes for rent both directly
and with partners we know that they are
insufficient to meet the level of need
for homes
we are therefore also committed through
our housing homeless and rough sleeper
strategy to explore new models of
funding and delivery and we'll continue
to keep this under review through the
work of our cabinet advisory group
thank you
thank you very much councillor beta
council um austin do you have the
supplementary i do chair thank you
councillor bayford uh in the light of
dramatically rising fuel bills and the
additional hardship caused to some of
our poorest families by the removal of
the universal credit uplift can cabinet
outline what steps we're taking to
ensure that all our housing is insulated
to a high standard in order both to meet
our client emergency commitments and to
help relieve fuel poverty thank you
thank you council austin thank you
councillor david
i'm not sure how related that is to the
first question but again our our housing
strategy on the um website covers
all those things okay thank you
yes that was very brave
thank you very much
thank you very much councillors moving
on to agenda item eight motions on
notice now we have three motions on
notice and in accordance with council
procedure rule three
please note that the time allowed for
consideration of motion shall not exceed
30 minutes i ask members to be as
succinct as possible
so straight on to agenda item eight a
emotional notice regarding disabled
persons parking bays i pulled on
councillor whitehead to introduce her
motion
and word
thank you very much chair um and as you
said i'm very aware that
we have a significant number of motions
this evening so i'll try and be as brief
as possible
the social model of disability as
opposed to the medical model of
disability argues that we are disabled
not by our medical and physical needs
but by our environment not adjusting to
those needs
in terms of our provision for disabled
parking we are currently not adjusting
the environment to the needs of our
residents
under kcc and tdc provision blue badge
holders can apply for a parking spot
based on their blue badge status
but that parking spot can be used by
anyone with a blue badge
this means that those who are most in
need in terms of mobility and access
so much so that they have been formally
assessed as requiring close and direct
access to their vehicle by local
authorities
can and often do lose that facility as
the parking spot that is intended
specifically to make their life easier
is not specifically allocated to them
making its purpose in relation to that
individual individual redundant
we not only need to recognize the
importance of disabled parking base
performing their actual function
but also assess the number of street
based bays we have generally available
in relation to the numbers of our
population requiring them to ensure that
we have sufficient provision
other councils are already leading on
this personalized bay permits are not a
new policy
hackney and tower hamlets and others
already offer personalized bay permits
to ensure that disabled individuals with
limited mobility can always access their
homes and vehicles without worry
i ask this council to commit to an
internal audit of the number of disabled
parking spaces available on our roads in
relation to the numbers of residents
requiring them
and to commit contacting and working
alongside kcc to bring forward a
personalized permit scheme so that our
application-based disabled parking bays
can finally perform the role that is
intended
thank you
yes um the actual wording of emotion
you might want to read out of course
to paraphrase
and this council commits to an internal
audit of the number of disabled parking
spaces available in relation to the
number of residents requiring them and
commits to contacting and working with
kcc to bring forward personalised
permits so that our application-based
disabled parking bays can perform the
role that is intended
thank you very much indeed councillor
whitehead have you a secondary i do
there i can't make it
councillor keane thank you very much
indeed councillor keem now what members
please note that in accordance with
council procedure rule 3.7 if the motion
is seconded then it will be referred to
capnet as it relates to a cabinet
function
that is unless council decides to debate
the motion now if council wishes to
debate the motion then following debate
the motion will be referred to cabinet
in accordance with council procedure
rules 3.8 a4
in accordance with council procedure
rule 3.7 a member of the controlling
political group is entitled to reply
so first instance i call upon counselor
david saunders
thank you chairman and thank you council
whitehead for your excellent preambles
i'm going to respond actually
to the motion
and for the benefit of members who are
not fully aware of the current situation
which obviously council whitehead is and
so am i from the various
communications i receive
from disabled residents in my world
so i just wanted to confirm that the
scheme of referred to is controlled by
kcc
under the existing agency agreement
whereby qualifying blue badge holders
can apply for a disabled bay to be
installed outside their residence
this very subject was in fact recently
covered under agenda item 8 of the joint
transportation board meeting on the 16th
of september
this scheme is managed by tdc on behalf
of kcc and details of the application
process as it currently stands can be
found on the website
in response to the question regarding
the number currently i can confirm there
are 164
on-street bays within the district and
up to 5
of parking bays or
parking positions within a road could be
designated as disabled bays on
application
this is the downside that you referred
to
if approved that's the application if
the approved if the application is
approved there's a one-off payment of
250 pounds to cover the amount of work
involved and to get the bay written into
a traffic regulation order
the kcc agreement does not allow
personalized permits for such base which
basically means that once installed any
blue badge holder can park within the
bay and i think that's the the knob but
as far as
i'm concerned we do know the number
the joint transportation board are
very aware of this situation and they
are regularly reviewing uh where we act
with it and also with kcc
chairman that's
my please
thank you very much indeed councillor
saunders now if council wish to debate
this motion i need a proposal and second
uh
do i have one
councillor organ proposed do you have a
second at council auburn
councillor keane thank you very much
indeed
i look for somebody to commence
yes sorry mike mikey can we have a vote
in favor of the to debate motion those
in favor please
and goes against the motion
and can have abstentions
thank you very much members so we will
not be debating the emotion uh but
nevertheless the um
the proposal the motion will be carried
forward to cabinet
moving therefore onto agenda item b and
we have a second motion on notice
regarding a joint local and national
government task force to plan action to
reach net zero emissions
and i call upon councillor ghana uh for
his motion council ghana
thank you thank you very much chair
as we all know this year
uh we host the very important cop 26
up in scotland in november
and i've bought this motion to be
considered by the council partly as a
response to a statement made by
alex sharma
mp who's president of cop 26
who said collaboration would be a key
objective of the climate summit in fact
he said
governments business and civil society
sometimes called non-state actors and
including local government need to work
together to transform the ways we power
our homes and businesses grow our food
develop infrastructure and move
ourselves and goods around
so the motion i'm bringing
to the meeting tonight is that in this
year of quick cop 26 that this council
adds our voice to calls by the local
government association and the
association of directors of environment
economy
planning and transport and others
for a joint local and national
government task force
to plan action to reach net zero
emissions
such a partnership can set appropriate
regulations benchmarks and targets and
create the much needed long-term funding
mechanisms to enable us in local gov
communities
and the economies to decarbonize whilst
remaining resilient and sustainable and
the second part of the motion is that we
ask that we write to al-aqsharma mp
the prime minister and the leadership
board of the lga informing them of our
support for a joint local national
government climate change partnership
task force and asking for one to be
established as soon as possible thank
you thank you very much indeed
councillor garner do you have a second
after that councillor wing thank you
very much indeed now in accordance with
council procedure 3.7 a member of the
controlling political group is entitled
to reply i therefore call upon
councillor bob bayford who is ready and
waiting to prepare and give us our
speak his speech for he's prepared for a
week i believe is it yeah
this one about five minutes chairman um
no i mean i i don't really have a speech
um if
if council ghana wishes to to debate
this happy to do that but i want to
assure him we support this motion
absolutely wholeheartedly
we support the the principle of it in
the first bit and i'm very happy to
commit to us writing to alex sharma
prime minister and the lga leadership
board quite honestly i think debating it
would be a waste of council's time we're
happy to support it absolutely 100 thank
you
thank you very much any councillor
bayford
uh
now then uh i should actually ask do we
wish to debate um
i'm quite happy with that commitment
from council bayford to do that that
there there is no need for a debate so
i'm happy to
leave it in council bayford's capable
hands to send those letters off to those
appropriate people
[Laughter]
right therefore members
counselor piper
thank you chair i'm sure i probably know
the answer to this already but just for
the benefit of the recording
uh clearly if there is no debate the
motion falls none of us wants the motion
to fall if there is going to be no
debate is it possible for you as
chairman to waive that condition
for this particular motion so that it
doesn't
require a debate failing that i'm quite
happy to have a one sentence
conversation with somebody from a
different political group so there has
been a debate
thank you councillor piper you have
preempted me and i was just about to put
it to the vote that we accept this
motion so those in favor of the wording
of the vote put by councillor ghana
could i please indicate
i think that's unanimous isn't it
thank you very much indeed
that will therefore be referred to
kaepernick as the previous motion
i have now the third agenda item
emotional notice regarding airbnb's
agenda item 8c i call upon councillor
yates
thank you jeff
um good evening everyone and members of
the public um i don't have long so i
just want to say some statistics and
briefly walk briefly walk you through
this motion
the statistics say that 33 of residents
in planet are renters there's been a 400
growth in airbnbs from 2016 to 2019.
there are over 300 whole property entire
place airbnb is available in margay
but only 15 rentable rental properties
available in market a typical rental
property in that goes around 800 pounds
a month the typical airbnb would charge
three thousand a month
well below the average take-home monthly
salary for local authentic resident of
one thousand seven hundred pounds after
tax
our own council and the kent fire and
rescue services have confirmed that they
do not know exactly how many whole
property airbnbs exist in planet
the core of this airbn motion airbnb
motion called point a is the council to
work with the local plan advisory group
to introduce planning rules that would
allow local people essay in whether a
house can be changed into a whole
property airbnb
this looks to give a community a say for
the first time over the future of their
streets and their neighborhoods in
relation to this
the second part of the motion looks to
introduce a cap within the airbnb
platform of 90 days for the whole
property airbnbs as happens in london it
does not look to restrict existing
short-term let property owners from
renting beyond those 90 days merely to
restrict the ability to advertise
through the platform
finally a few quotes
harry who's the owner of the
award-winning batega cruise restaurant
in margate says that we've lost and
we're losing staff at our work because
they can't find places to rent
aleister baldwin from holiday latin kent
said on bbc radio ken this morning that
he does believe that we do need
regulation
and finally the chair of the bed and
breakfast association last year said
that airbnb was reckless in its
disregard for uk law and regulations
so onto the motion
this council notes with concern the
ongoing issues raised by residents
around the growth in airbnbs and thani
especially in relation to the reduction
in long-term rentable properties we
welcome the majority of visitors to
thanet who make an important
contribution to our economy but we hear
residents concerns and wish to take
action to control this serious issue
which is damaging our community and
damaging the reputation of airbnb this
council recognises that currently does
not possess the powers to intervene and
regulate these properties and this is a
problem faced by many local authorities
across the country
therefore this council resolves to a
work with the local planned cabinet
advisory group to try and introduce
planning restrictions that affect
short-term rentals such as change of use
regulations that are required in greater
london to turn a property into an airbnb
property and b asked the leader of
council to write to mary laurimer the uk
public policy manager at airbnb to
request a meeting and seek to
proactively introduce a 90-day annual
limit for entire home rentals in thanet
within the airbnb platform airbnb
currently has a lock on their platform
that does not allow greater london and
tire home properties to be rented out
for more than 90 days a year i propose
this motion
thank you very much council yates
now
is do you have a second account for
yates
councillor arum roth i believe yes
now in accordance with council procedure
rule 3.7 a member of the controlling
political group is entitled reply
i therefore call upon counselor jill
bayford who will be able to refer to a
previous answer
i think
thank you indeed indeed i will thank you
chair um although committed to
determining the impact of airbnbs on the
rental market this administration does
not feel that it's appropriate to pro
propose any policy change changes
concerning airbnb without properly
quantifying the actual impact of air b
me on the rental property market and its
contribution to than its touring economy
this is sorry
this administration is committed to
exploring whether new policies in
respect of airbnb might be beneficial
but these must be measured and
reasonable and formulated against a
backdrop of factual information
on this basis we don't believe that
debating this motion is helpful thank
you
thank you very much indeed councillor
bayford
now members should note that as only
council can adopt this motion or notice
the motion will fall if the council does
not agree to debate it
can i have a proposal and a second to
debate the motion
councillor alban seconded councillor
roth
right those in favor to debate the
motion good to have your hands
thank you very much can i have those
against debating the motion
thank you very much can i have
abstentions
and i don't see any extensions
thank you very much we will not be
debating the motion this evening
therefore the motion falls
thank you very much moving on to agenda
item nine uh the leaders report i call
upon councillor ashby
thank you chair
sunny district's council's annual
residence survey of 6 000 people is well
underway inviting our residents to have
their say and what is really important
to them
as world councils we are all aware of
the subjects of complaints that we are
asked to deal with this coupled with the
survey outcome will focus on where the
council services should be prioritized
our challenge comes when trying to
address the expectations of delivering
improvements in the areas that our main
concern with the restraints of reduced
resources
hard decisions have to be made every
year during the budget building process
and this year will be no exception
but as a council we have to constantly
look at ways that improve efficiency
whilst maintaining standards and
delivering a balanced budget
revenue income from new additional
sources are vital for the future
survival of all local authorities and
the sound commercial strategy is a must
for the future
as our season summer season draws to a
close and the sleepy autumn days are
upon us it is time to look at the impact
on the visitor economy
from both income and benefits to the
district but also the cost of the
council for town and beach safety and
management and cleanup operations
the staycation produced an increase in
visitors and train travel to than it
alone increased by 71 during the peak
season
this trend is predicted to continue
into next year and beyond
i think members will agree that the
beach management plan which was
implemented for the second consecutive
season has proved very successful and
maintained a structured approach for the
district
a massive eighteen
one thousand eight hundred tons of
litter was collected throughout the
season
seven thousand hours of litter picking
completed across eight of this most
popular beaches by council staff which
does not include the incredible efforts
from the local community and groups for
litter picking in many areas across the
aisle for whom we should be most
thankful
the main conundrum for the council is to
find a way to generate revenue from
visitors that offsets the operational
costs paid for by local residents that
doesn't harm the business economy by
deterring visits visitors from coming to
our beautiful beaches towns and villages
a local tourist levy may be something
that could be considered as it has been
done in various other city locations and
heavy tourism areas at present there is
very little evidence to the benefits or
downsides but a voluntary scheme could
be a good starting point
part of our climate and biodiversity
emergency declaration has seen the
launch of a different approach to work
on council maintained flower beds in
various coastal locations
a move away from the more traditional
planting of angles and replace them with
perennials plants may improve
biodiversity and help to create habitats
for pollinators such as bees butterflies
and moths
which we know are in serious decline and
also
will also enhance soul life and
importantly vital
and importantly increase the visual
appeal and beauty of the beds for the
residents and visitors who enjoy them
the council has commissioned full street
place consultants to carry out a
feasibility study on the redevelopment
of westbrook bloggia at westbrook bay
and
as wool councillor i'm looking forward
to seeing the outcome of the survey
which asks for people's views on a
sustainable year-round use
the log ear was originally constructed
as a bathing pavilion in the early 1900s
and the building owned by fanuc district
council is currently empty except for a
selection of a section occupied by panic
lifeguards and your leisure
over the years it has been difficult for
the council to find the funds to
maintain our iconic coastal buildings
and it is very sad for us to see them
falling to disrepair over the years
hopefully this will find a solution for
the building and restore it to its
former glory that is sustainable for
both the community and visitors alike
the pandemic was a devastating blow to
all parts of the community and
businesses now it is vital for the local
economy recovery that we all support our
local traders and recognize that use it
or lose it is a very much reality
statement
during october the fiverr fest which is
part of the totally local campaign
is an initiative for independent
businesses to encourage people back to
our towns and village centres by
offering five pound bargains
there will be posters in shop windows
and information about the campaign is
available in our social media channels
october marks the first anniversary of
our in-house tenant and leaseholder
services
the service was set up in october 2020
to manage our residential properties and
currently looks after over
3400 individual properties following the
disbanding of ekh
the key aim was to improve the service
levels along with improving the
condition of our estates and rectifying
health and safety issues identified
under the ekh tenure
the new term the new team now numbers 58
and is a mix of east kent housing and
new staff
the team has received skilled skills
training and is fully focused on
improving the services we provide to
tenants and leaseholders
a number of initiatives to improve how
the team communicate with our customers
are now in place and a service
improvement plan has been developed
which includes working on a wide range
of projects such as improving the
appearance of the estate
identifying new heating solutions for
the tower blocks
i believe
that since the service has been brought
in-house and i'm sure the cabinet holder
councillor joe bayford would agree that
there has been a major improvement in
the all-round service bob porter and his
team and all associated with the
integration should be congratulated for
their efforts in what has appeared to be
a very smooth process with very little
if any interruption to the service
there are various town projects ongoing
which i'll update as follows the work
continues on our ramsgate future
initiative to create a plan for the
future of ramsgate that supports a
thriving town centre and the needs for
local people
the ramsgate town
future town investment plan pulls
together existing schemes like the
future high street fund the high street
heritage action zone to create a vision
to transform the town
the public engagement stage has now
finished and the next step is pulling
together the feedback to finalize the
document which is due to be published
next month
this week we launched a survey for local
people to have their say on proposed
highway improvements in ramsgate on
tuesday the 12th of october as part of
the future high street fund
the council is looking for feedback on
improvements to the roads and pedestrian
areas of ramsgate with a view to create
a more welcoming space for pedestrians
and to reduce the dominance of cars in
the area
as well as contribute to the wider
generation of the town centre
the marlgate town deal process has now
entered phase two of the town deal
process which includes the development
of the green book business cases
to demonstrate the feasibility viability
and value for money of the projects
external consultants prd limited have
been appointed to assist the board with
this process
the first business case summary will be
submitted to government in the next week
or so
i very much enjoyed my visit to the
ramsgate 200th roll harbour status
celebrations on the 25th of september
and are taking part in the parade and
watching the morning
drum head service the long history of
the harbour and the visit by king george
iv in 1821 which resulted in him gifting
the role ascent is something we should
all be proud of and cherish
especially as it's the only role harbour
in the country
landscape football club should also be
congratulated in the work they are doing
for the community especially in relation
to the hacc program
during my visit back in the school
holidays summer holidays i witnessed the
benefit of the hab programme that was
have was having the benefits that the
program was having for both children and
parents it was explained to me that the
government scheme although supporting
the main holidays was not supporting the
half-term holiday
the one that is actually coming up in a
couple of weeks time i approached river
road strategic partners to see if they
would be willing to contribute who have
not only agreed the funding for the hot
meals for the course but i've also
arranged for flight stimulators vr
headsets for which the children can
learn about vocational jobs and much
more for the hard term holiday
i was hoping to end my report on a high
note and report the good news that
following the southern water incident at
fullness pumping station back in june
that a regular communication line
between the council and southern walter
had been established a members briefing
with the southern wall to chief
executive ian mccauley had taken place a
payment of a hundred thousand to the
council in recognition of my request for
compensation for junior incident had
been made and the statement from
southern water that they had authorized
the drainage study for sanic at cost to
southern water of 400 million
of course
all of this is now marred by yet another
major incident on tuesday the 5th of
october at jos bay pumpkin station my
understanding is that electrical failure
occurred at 8 45 am and the backup
generator did not kick in
due to the need for a qualified
electrician to isolate the problem the
site did not come back online until 10
30 a.m
during that period unscreened wastewater
was discharged through the short sea
outfall
tdc was not notified of this discharge
by southern also and in fact the problem
was identified by the tdc officer just
fishing off jail
at the time of writing this report the
advice debaters not to enter the water
and walk below the high water might was
it was in place but i'm pleased between
sorry between westbrook and western
undertake landscape but i am
slightly the bearer of better news is
today
and 13 out of the 14 base have now had
the restrictions lifted but joss bay
remains under warning
as i stated in my numerous tv interviews
and statements in the res to the
residents and businesses this is totally
unacceptable and simply should not have
happened any organization that relies on
the power supply to operate any vital
part of their operational infrastructure
should have backups that are fully
tested and ready for operational
operation when needed
i have written to ian mccauley
requesting a meeting to discuss this
matter which is now being arranged for
i believe the week after next i have
also requested that our mps take the
matter up in parliament letters to the
environment agency and off what are also
on the way
expressing my deep concern and complete
frustration on this matter thank you
chair
thank you very much indeed leader uh
i did feel we did want to hear
everything that we had here about
southern water there it's important for
us to hear that uh moving on to um
councillor effort to comment on
questions in relation to the leaders
report council everett
thank you chair
um i'd like to thank the leader for the
advanced copy of europol
um and i believe that um she may be
celebrating a significant birthday this
week
so i will wish her happy birthday you'll
be pleased to hear that i won't be
singing unlike councillor python for
previous version
um i don't propose comment on everything
that she said um i'm glad that she's
found a wide range of topics to talk
about lots of things going on in the
district
um a bit disappointing therefore that
next week's cabinet meetings been
cancelled and there's been very little
business at the last two cabinet
meetings i know these things do happen
from time to time um but there's a
slight
it's like oddity there so no doubt
there'd be more business coming forward
in the future the resident survey is
important not least to see how public
opinion evolves over time but all
councillors are active in their world
should have a good idea of public
priorities especially around the public
realm and efficiency the council's
challenge whoever is in charge is in
delivering cleaner streets and public
spaces in particular without spending
more money
can she reassure us also that the
council is able to recruit to any
vacancies that he does have in
enforcement street cleansing and waste
collection on the wages that he pays and
if there are staff shortages what plans
does she have to deal with them so they
don't further impact on residents
she mentions the growth in the visitor
economy and notwithstanding the issue of
airbnbs we will recognize how important
it is to the prosperity of the district
and she mentioned the significance of
the beach management plan
and i think that that and the lessons
learned last year um it does seem that a
lot of good work has been done of course
that was done under the labour
administration
but of course obviously we rely on our
officers whichever political party is in
control
another issue which was resolved under
the labour administration i have to
point out was council housing management
being brought back in house and the
subsequent transition and i do
congratulate the officers involved as i
think they've done a great job as did
the then cabinet member councillor
whitehead
i also want to welcome the recent
housing surgeries including the ones
i've attended in newington i think
that's a really good initiative as it
gives the opportunity to discuss the
issues on the ground where we can see
them not just with the residents but
also between ward councillors and
officers and i hope that they're going
to carry on
in terms of the ramsgate future
initiative which was also kicked off by
labour i'm pleased to see the future
high street and heritage action zone
initiatives progressing
i hope that we're going to hear about a
successful outcome for both the
levelling upbeats around the time of the
chancellor's budget statement at the end
of the month because the one in ramsgate
certainly can make a real difference to
the town
like many members i went on the recent
tour of southern waters pumping station
at cliftonville and i don't question the
good intentions of some of their staff
who we met
unfortunately it felt pretty pointless
as she said a few days later there was
yet another system failure yet another
sewage discharge
and as she tells us the council wasn't
even notified
i don't really know what more we can do
as elected members
but the public certainly needs to
understand that the council shares its
frustration and we on this side echo
what she said about it
um i've also visited ramsgate football
club to see their new artificial pitch
as you might expect
and i've introduced them to some of the
key people at the heart of the community
in newington to try to maximize the
benefit of their community work with
some of our most disadvantaged residents
and i do think what rams gate football
club is doing is excellent
i don't have any issue with rsp funding
some of those activities
because whatever you think the future of
madison should be there's no question
that ramsgate and fanuc have been
damaged economically by the apparently
never ending delay in deciding the
future of the site and rsp are in part
at least responsible for that delay
if the local plan review wasn't being
delayed for other reasons we'd probably
have to put that on hold to wait for the
secretary of state to make his dco
decision and the likely fallout from
that to
flow through
so we don't agree councillor ashby and i
on what the decision should be and we
never will agree on it but can she least
can she at least agree with me
that she will press the secretary of
state to get on the mate one
thank you very much indeed councillor
everett leader we should respond
uh okay um i only picked up one sort of
main question um is regarding the uh
staff shortages i mean this is a
national problem
um i can't
recall that i think the numbers are over
a million
vacancies within the country
um so staff shortages is a horrendous
problem over a hundred thousand truck
drivers just alone
the council um i believe have um coped
really well with uh especially with the
lorry driver uh situation in that there
has been very little disruption to our
refuge collection so i think the
department
responsible for that should be commended
um that we've kept ourselves going
unlike brighton that i think is knee
high in rubbish as we speak
well i
wasn't going to mention the party but
i was just complimenting our council i i
don't need to uh
to mention other parties um
i take on board um that a lot of work
for the um beach management was
established under
actually cancer organs
and um i thank the the labour group for
setting things up so it makes my life so
easy in the in the two years that i have
to uh manage
um the start they said the boys yeah the
boys weren't um i'll be out there
um
i would agree with you it is incredibly
frustrating the delay to um on the
decision for manston airport and like
yourself although we don't want the same
outcome the same decision um there will
be there are a lot of noises being made
regarding speeding this up because it is
affecting our local plan it affects all
the islands strategy on how we move
forward so i can write to the secretary
of state i'm sure he'll take lots of
notice of me but i will write thank you
thank you very much indeed leader i call
upon the council of reverend piper to
come on or quest ask questions in
relation to the leaders report
you chair
um
as councillor everett has already said
it is a very thorough and fulsome report
uh and we thank you for that it is a
an opportunity that we have to hear from
you just some of the things and i'm
absolutely certain it's not all of the
things that you've been involved in on
our behalf
i would just
like to add that all our thanks should
go
to all of those people who got dirty
cleaning up for the benefit of the rest
of us the figures that you mentioned in
terms of litter
and visitors it's just astonishing the
amount of muck that visitors and local
residents it has to be said leave behind
so our thanks should go to everyone who
got dirty on our behalf
um
i think we've got a uh
we've got a slight conundrum coming
that's for sure if we work really hard
at uh preventing cars from coming into
our town centers to do any shopping the
council isn't going to get any parking
money which is a problem for us further
down the road i feel sure
and i would find myself wondering how
much people would have to pay
to park their car in order to go and buy
their item for a fiver from the local
business in the middle of the town
centre
i just of course
um and finally really thank you for
all your hard work
with southern water i know because
you've been kind enough to phone from
time to time and provide updates uh the
work that you have done with them
and with officers of the council to help
to try and resolve
these issues and
to a fellow wordy nerdy mr chairman i
would just say that i mean issues in
every sense
of the word thank you for your report
leader
thank you very much indeed councillor
piper anything you'd like to add to that
leela
yes um thank you for your comments
councillor piper it was quite nice to
see him a calling in front of the audit
coming to yesterday feeling the heat um
i always struggle a little bit with this
i must confess and so it was nice to see
that he was getting some stick there
thank you very much uh counselor ghana
called upon you to comment or ask
questions in relation to the leaders
report thank you
well um going last i
i also um
like to start by like councillors edward
and piper thank any free report and for
the
quite extensive updates it contains on a
number of positive projects and
initiatives taking place across the the
district
in phanet
we're very lucky to have a team of
hard-working officers
plus a wide variety of community groups
and individuals who work to make our
community a better place for both
residents and visitors
they do this in a number of different
ways some of which the leader mentions
in our report
it might be by helping to collect some
of the 1800 tonnes of litter left on our
beaches and in our towns this year
or it might be as part of one of the
many gardening groups
she mentions across the district working
to create
more of the habitats for pollinators
and improving the aesthetics of our
towns and villages at the same time
or it might also be by responding to one
of the many surveys mentioned because i
have a good understanding of what needs
to happen in their area
and are passionate about making things
better for everyone who live
lives here and who visit
and finally it might also be because
they run a small business and have
struggled during the pandemic
so are taking part in the fiverr fest as
part of the totally locally campaign
which we should all support
so with all that hard work and community
involvement i have to say that it comes
as a real slap in the face to all of
them and all of us
when we have to suffer yet another
southern water sewage discharge causing
more devastating damage to our coastline
and closing our beaches for even longer
than the last time
after the sewage leak
in fullness in june
caused by a power failure following a
lightning strike
we listened to ian mccauley and his team
promised to urgently improve the
situation
he told us this was a priority for him
and yet here we are a couple of months
down the line and another power failure
at another of their pumping stations
it's almost as if they're doing all they
can to make life as difficult as
possible for us and the people of
thailand
mr bakari and his team need to be made
to pay for this continued negligence
which allows our coastline to be
decimated while their shareholders
collect their dividends
well it's not our gift to bring them to
book legally and i'm pleased to hear
that a criminal investigation is
underway we certainly need to seek a
much larger recompense from them than
the hundred thousand they paid for the
last discharge from four nests
if they can afford multi-million pound
payouts to their shareholders they can
certainly afford to pay a seven-figure
sum for us to use to invest in new
facilities
including toilet blocks around the
coastline for residents and visitors to
use as well as to fund other significant
environmental improvement and other
projects that many community groups are
currently struggling to find funds to
progress
mr mccauley and his team are responsible
for causing great damage to the
reputation of our area
we should make sure that they are
responsible for paying reparations to
make it good again
thank you
thank you very much councillor ghana of
course many of those shareholders are
pension funds
uh have you said that
leader would you like to respond
so they didn't pick up any uh direct
questions but again you know southern
water is is top of our list um
i will be writing as you can imagine and
having some words um
and i was envisioning sticking another
naught on the end of it so um
i'm not saying that i haven't got any
sort of leverage to get that i would
love to take them to court but this
council can't afford to do that and i'll
leave that to the environment the
environment agency because
they're they're the ones that fund their
the legal cases but unfortunately
they're the ones that get the 90 million
that went into the coffers uh the last
time and that doesn't disseminate back
down to the district's
authorities that actually uh suffer from
it so
that might be a question for the
environment agency that if they would
like to share some of that
for the june spill no doubt i think
they'll be pushing again for another
legal challenge they might well join the
two together
but we are in constant touch with the
environment agency so yes needless to
say i will be um well it won't be
writing it'll be a visit um
with mr mccauley
along with the chief executive and with
the two mps um
and
like all i can say is that the kicking
that he got last time will be twice as
hard this time so i will ask for a
million whether we get it or not it'll
be another matter thank you
thank you very much indeed leader and we
look forward to the one of those
millions coming our way
a general item 10 report of the chair of
the overview and scrutiny panel now bob
uh council david i see on the edge of
your chair but you and i know that's
your favorite committee but the chairman
is an actual fact councillor piper
councillor piper
yeah he's a horse actor fellow chair
that's for sure
chairman i'd like to offer my thanks to
mr charles hungway and mr nick hughes
for their admin support for this
committee sometimes it is quite
substantial
and to members of the committee who've
sat and considered
items at our overview and scrutiny
meetings we are progressing through
the work schedule
and are always open to receive ideas of
topics for consideration we're looking
into next year from easter onwards at
the moment
this report of course outlines our work
program with some feedback of things
that have already happened and things
that are to happen
in the near future
i would also like to thank
mr hughes and ms culligan for offering
members the training program around
overview and scrutiny recently which
gave us all really an insight into the
business of calling of decisions
uh it was not done in any way to prevent
callings but really to educate us so
that we knew how to call the subject in
and it didn't fall at a a seemingly uh
ridiculous little hurdle
where it hadn't quite met the bar
so thank you for offering the training
i'm not yet aware of exactly how many
people attended but i intended myself
and it was very informative
members there it is i commend the report
to you along with an invitation if
there's nothing you can think of at this
precise moment that you'd like us to
look at an invitation to write in and
ask us to look at subjects you might
want us to review in the future thank
you thank
you thank you very much indeed casper
piper do members have any comments
i don't see
always a good sign of a report when
there aren't any comments
agenda item 11 capital programme scheme
ramsgate future high street fund i call
upon councillor pew to introduce
councillor pew
thank you chair
this report is requesting the approval
of additional of adding an additional
scheme into the capital program for the
town's fund the council was successfully
awarded just over 2.7 million for two
projects in ramsgate including a highway
scheme and the delivery of a creative
workspace in the town centre
this is the maximum award from the
department for leveling up housing and
communities and the capital funding
within our program will be no more than
the total
two two million seven hundred and four
thousand
two hundred and thirteen pounds
all the investment and costs associated
with the delivery of the future high
street fund projects are fully funded
from external grants and contributions
and all expenditure relating to the
interventions
will be managed the total package of
funding provided to ensure there is no
risk of financial exposure to the
council
i recommend approval
uh that an allocation is made in the
capital program
in order that the council may deliver
these capital two capital projects thank
you
yes thank you very much indeed council
pew i have a second after that council
bayford
thank you very much do members agree
thank you very much agenda item 12
the annual treasury management review
for 2020 21. i call upon councillor
david saunders
thank you chairman and i'm afraid
members there's an error of deja vu as i
read out
my introduction to this report and
indeed the report itself
the the introduction reads the report
summarizes a background look
on our treasury management activity for
20
20 21 the figures remain provisional
because our 2020
and 21 accounts have still not as yet
been audited and are therefore subject
to change until the audit is completed
the regulatory environment places
responsibility on members for the review
and scrutiny of treasury management
policy and activities this report is
therefore important in that respect as
it provides details of the 20 20 21 year
end position for treasury activities
firstly i am pleased to report that all
of our activities operated within the
limits agreed by members
but the other key messages that i have
summarized from the report are
that our capital expenditure and was
significantly under budget
as detailed in the following budget our
turn report
that we repaid
pounds of 631.000 during the year and
undertook no new borrowing
that our average debt position was 25
million and that we did not borrow more
money than we needed to finance our
capital program
as such we stayed well within our
authorized limit of 109 million pounds
i move the recommendation as detailed in
12.1
thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
saunders have i got a second offer that
councillor bayford again
two members agree
agreed thank you very much
moving on to agenda item 13 statement of
community involvement review results of
public consultation and adoption i call
upon the leader councillor ashby
thank you chair
the statement of community involvement
sets out how the council will consult on
planning issue policy
sorry planning policy issues planning
applications and neighborhood plans the
sci was originally adopted in council in
2007 a revised and updated sci was
adopted by council in twelve
it is considered appropriate that the
sci should be reviewed now in line with
the forthcoming local plan review and to
reflect changes in methods and
communications and engagement
there is also a requirement under the
town and country planning regulation
that scis are reviewed every five years
the council carried out a public
consultation on the sci review from the
25th of february to the 9th of april
2021
this report sets out the main issues
raised in response to that consultation
any resulting changes to be made to the
sci
i recommend that the council adopt and
publish the revised statement of
community involvement thank you chair
thank you council ashby do you have a
secondary
councillor bayford again
do members agree
thank you very much indeed gender item
14 representation on outside bodies
i move as chairman of the council
agrees to add the manston skills and
employment board to the list of
executive outside bodies do i have a
second for that
council peter
no
instead
do members agree
thank you
general item 15 appointment of the
grievance committee and grievance
appeals committee for statutory officers
i hope the council approves the
recommendations in the report can i have
a secondary
councillor saunders
do members agree go cancel everett do
you wish to say speak thank you i do
chair thank you and i'm going to speak
very narrowly to the report members will
be pleased to hear um i just want you to
draw members attention to the fact that
this item has been
a very long while in the works
and members of gp
general purposes will know that this
matter was discussed as long ago as
january 2020 and as the report notes
general purposes eventually considered
the policy on the 30th of september 2020
when it came back from ekhr
the
joint services arrangement for dealing
with hr
um i think it's unsatisfactory that it's
taken that this long to get not only to
that meeting but also to come before the
council tonight but i do understand that
um it does involve some contractual
negotiation with our secretary offices
because it's not a statutory process of
itself
um nevertheless i think it should be
understood that it has been in the works
and that it has been brought forward and
members have done their bit in bringing
it forward and i also just want to draw
attention to the paragraph 1.1
where it talks about the the policy and
it says gpc had requested that a policy
be written that closely reflects the
joint negotiating committee jnc model
grievance procedures for chief
executives
now that's what we've got in front of us
that's what we should have in front of
us and i get a bit fed up with listening
to people outside the council
who seem to be of opinion that members
did not want to or do not intend to
follow the jnc model for grievance
procedures that is what we are agreeing
hopefully tonight members and i hope
people outside the council get that
message too thank you
yes we'll indulge that um this is the
final piece of the jigsaw that needs to
be completed for the processes so i'm
pleased that this has come this far um
the delay was some not really the the
fault of uh necessarily members or even
officers putting it together there were
just some
regularities that had to be ironed out
before we got there but um i would
commend um estelle for her work on this
because it has been a
difficult document to get together and
finalise so
i would uh
if it is for second in chair i will
second i also can give the names for the
representatives from our group if you
wish
thank you very much indeed
uh
i don't see any any other comments uh
therefore can members agree this
appointment
thank you very much indeed
agenda item 16 report back from the east
kent joint independent remuneration
panel regarding amendments to members
allowance scheme for 2021-2022
this is report is for information only
would members note the report
agenda item 17 changes to committees
panels and boards
respect with respect to proportionality
following consensus between the group
leaders i move the council approves the
proportionality between groups and
committees panels and boards the
remainder of
the
2021-22 municipal year shown in the
paragraph 4.1.1 of the report can i have
a seconder
counselor ashby
now do members agree
thank you
moving on to nomination of members to
serve on committees group leaders may
take this opportunity to advise of
changes to the nominations to committees
panels and boards that remained with the
21 22 year
council ashby do you wish to advise of
any nomination changes
no chad would like to defer my decisions
until the next full council meeting
thank you
fair enough thank you councillor
councillor piper
thank you chair councillor braidwood to
standards
uh councillor john dennis to licensing
and councillor linda potts to take this
seat on the housing cabinet advisory
group thank you
thank you councillor piper councillor
ghana
thank you yeah i'll um councillor ghana
myself i shall be on planning and
councillor wing will now be reserved for
non-planning
thank you very much indeed castle ghana
moving on to agenda item 18 exclusion of
the public and press would members
please refer to supplementary agenda
number one now i move that the public
and press be excluded from the meeting
for agenda item 19 as it contains exempt
information as defined in paragraph 2
and 5 of part 1 of the schedule 12a of
the local government act 1972 as amended
can i have a second app